Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Going Home"
Now this is a pixelated style horror game that should explore... A lot of multiple possibilities
Who's supposed to have multiple endings based on the choices that I make and I don't know how In depth that goes
But I always like an opportunity for my actions to really impact the game. music by Brandon. *Claps* Oh way to go Brandon!
Wazwhazisdat? Ah. Art by Brandon!?
*Claps again* Hey good job Brandon! Oh, man! You're doing great!
You're doing everybody proud.
(What?)
A game by Brandon?! Aw come on brandon. You can do no better
*Mysterious Knock Is Very Mysterious*
Hi, okay. Hello
*Confused/Disturbed Markimoo*
Claire...
Alex... I'm here. Where are you two?
"Why is it so dark in here? The storm must have caused the blackout good thing I brought"
...
"My flashlight"
(What'd you think? A burger?)
Oh.
Alright, why am I meeting Alex and Claire here? Why- Woah. Hi? Okay?
*Disturbed Markicow*
Okay...So wha-
*Slight Screech*
*Markimoo sh!ts his pants*
Alright...
*Slightly Fasted Pitch*
Oh am I supposed to be doing something here?!
...Oooooooooooooooh...
Ahhh...
I don't like that. That actually sends chills up my spine. Woo Bright!
Hello, how do I- I "have to find them first" Am I gonna find their bodies?
Oh I have a funny feeling that we're gonna find their bodies here. Okay. I have to find them first, okay, I get it
Why am I breathing so weird? okay. I get it- *Sexually Frustrated Groan*  Let me find em!
All right, I don't know where my friends are but I bet they're deeaaaaaaaaaaaad. (Never rely on this man to look for you.)
Okaaaaaay...
I Gotta admit for being low res. This is legitimately creepy.
I don't like the flashlight mechanic because I know you're gonna hide stuff in the darkness from me.
Why is there a basketball hoop in their goddamn place?
It's locked I need to find the key oh, do I-
Oh, do I, what do I need to find the key?
All right.
Hi, hello. Is that a teddy bear or is that a body?! (Really seems to want to find a body.)
Okay, that his toys, lifty lews, (What?) also known as weights.
Where are they? I have to look for them. I know what do you think I was doing? *Super loud screeching noise that seems really out of place and sudden*
What was that? I have to find them quick. All right? Okay? This is a shelf. OHHHHHHHHHH,
very
observant. Look inside? Sure. Im going to go with that. Oh, you got the revolver part. It's a barrel.
There's nothing more here? Okay. All righty then. I got a revolver part. I don't know why. There's a shoe rack.
Its unattended for some time. Check inside?
Just worn out shoes. How inside a shoe rack can you look?
AHHHH AYE
Excuse you. You want to tell me what that was? Huh? Oh- AUHUA
Okay, alright. I don't like this. Wow Ohhh oh. Ohhhhh.
Sit down? Why would I sit down? I have nothing to do.
Goddamn right I have nothing to do. Oh, these are colorful sticky notes and a picture of me and my wife with our
child. Oh.
Just foods. Good. I don't know. Trash bin. It's full smells terrible. Check inside?
Maybe there's a matchstick all right large apparatus for this kitchen
These are shelves on top drawers on the bottom gives you stuff placeholders, and I think
Check the drawers. Yes
Why raisins are my kitchen?
back on laughs all
Right it's a realist painting. It's literally weird stare at it. Okay. Let's do that. No one understands it no one understands me
Hey
I like it an abstract painting quite bothering creeps me outside
Then we'll both be creeped out, right?
I don't know. I am okay. I don't know how I got here. I don't on a child crib bear
Teddy Bears and some tub toys small paper drawings check it sure a child's art
I guess wow it's wobbly. Oh, what am I doing?
House why is there someone fell off the Roof? Oh?
Huh?
mf hf m f hf
May I
Don't know if this means put it the puzzle
Mom fell
Hit face. I don't know
Having a full clothes handbags. There's a dot slacks as a compartment open it shirt boy hammer
Toy hammer I guess that's good for me. I want to use hammer things boys
More toys stuff away, the old dumbbells mmM is a box okay?
Arm air pumping I got an air pumper good I know I know
I'm so annoying is the lock one right? I don't know these are candle holders light it sure
Okay, something clicked hello. What are you the drawer sure forget a revolver part?
I got a cylinder furrow. Why do I need a gun?
The lock no cash you have to find the key but at least I lit those
Tie okay. No okay. No, okay. Fine. That's
Sports ball quite less bouncy, maybe I should pump air sure okay
Excuse the air bubbler you got the basketball. There's a basketball hoop over there. Why is my house full of puzzles. I don't know
My knees are tired sit down now. I'm good. I don't want to I want to sit down good
Hey
Are you doing that to me? Don't do that to me large shellings tools equipment parts some are still working others?
They're just junk search through it, okay. Nothing useful here great. That was a waste of my time and yours
safe vault need a combination only
With the combination be I don't even know how to use this numbers
one two three four five six seven eight nine, ten eleven
back
Work, okay. Don't know why whoo box containing nuts bolts nails and more certs inside, okay?
Nothing useful here all right fine menthol sounds going to be feel bad russkies it no, not yet
I shouldn't yeah, I'm not going to sit down not in this house
Basketball hoop, but the net is tied out put a ball in it sure
We clicked like one
Saybolt Click ok nope
Not today not today. Go. Oh my God, not today. Come on. I need to get down there. Oh
Gracious they're out of here. It's beautiful
Oh this one's a nice one the other one is adapt one this one fine
Portrait of an animal head to lion quite corrosion break it sure you use the hammer
That toy hammer did a doozy on that one the painting fell whole look like
Slashes the boxes over to exercise what box I picked up the cue
Okay, alright, then I picked up the key so I can go unlock that door up there
Yes, okay, so one more room over if he's doing bag you want to stop okay?
creative
You use the key it opened now, okay, where I?
Don't like that. I have to find them quick
The Flashlight won't last oh
Alex
Okay, I guess final quick
Frame and remember something picked off sure it's hard, it's too
Sour man looks like the news check under it okay. There's a key. There's a spatula keychain
Oh, it's the kitchen is that what it is. Ooh good okay? Oh my God. I can't see that
Sure, there's a peanut in here. Nothing else here. Okay. I got to go to the kitchen. Hope I'm gonna go all this way oh
Okay, I got a guy got off come on. Come on. No no no. Oh you snack. Yeah
Guru, okay, yeparooni took it. No topper and ammo no
Mmm. I'm in the kitchen. You sack of shit. Okay here. We go
All right shelves on top see uh check the drawers. Yes
There's a crowbar
Oh, okay pick that up
So I can go back up to the bedroom and then I can place it on the thing ain't no one's here
Alright, so if I just keep going over there to my whoop, and it's clear. We've let it stay clear
Regularly check the attic in bed the letters are smudged. There's a tiny lever pull it sure oh something fell. What is that?
Zack with the rope it leads to the attic pull it yes, ladder fell all right. What is that?
The Corp where's their cord touch it sure?
so responding oh
Going up random pickles. How there's no like crispy turn it off
sure
Unit won't turn off okay. I'm going up to the attic that leads to the attic
climb up
Your grandpa's old clock. I remember it's not working when Grandpa died last autumn. It's working now
Something's not right open it. I must input the compensation. Oh, I don't know the common
Yeah
Cobwebs and dust all over open. It sure it's locked of course it is what else isn't like a goddamn house of mine?
This is my house, right?
fuck was that I
Don't like it
These to our room. Go down sure I got nothing else to do so I got to keep going forward I
Don't know where to go. Who are ok, I'm out. I'm out. I'm out here
Alright ok so go the other way now. Hey there
My lovely wife so if I go back to the kids room
And I look at the drawings there must be like if I solve that puzzle
Here this must be it so it must relate to this so mom
fell
and then
Mom fell
His fault mom fell his fault. Oh, mom fell his fault so that must be the code
There we go got it. Okay. Got that safe fold. I need a combination. I just opened it
You got the row you've got the revolver part. It's the hammer have all the parts
I need it able to rebuild it no one here, okay?
So I just got to go over to the kitchen and do this. I think kitchen table nothing special sit down
Yes rebuild the revolver rebuild the gun here, so do it. Oh
Done, it's fellig agents. You've got a revolver. Okay alrighty then so now what oh
oh
That's why all the things were the same exact answer the whole time. Oh look at it. Oh, there's a joke if visions
eat
That's a book of the bible like things which
ha
Okay
ephesians is
the tenth
book so the fusions to eight might mean
1028 on the clock and if that's the case then I should be able to put it in there
But I'm not on represent sure now that I know my navigation skills are working properly
I can't believe I've gotten through the whole game by doing that that's amazing
yes, okay, so if I can go to ten to
eat
Do it let's do it come on. Oh wait
He inside. Oh you get the clock t. So they did work. That's so weird that I have to go into it twice
I'll talk you that oh my God
What the fuck?
Faint sound wait, what happened did I die?
Mom
Dad
Had a neighbor. What's happening?
socks ha ha ha
Mom
Mel happening what happened? Oh, hi, okay? Oh this? Oh look at me. Go. I'm a wily one
There in the attic I can't reach the ladder
Okay
Alright, then I guess I'll go on my way. Oh
It looks a lot. It looks a lot simpler now that uh
Now that everything is out in the open what what in the world did that do?
Share oh
Take it to bang okay. Let's push it I
will just do shit a boosh it all the way and
Bouche is sufficiently. I can now reveal a door go off
Hello. Why are you up here? I?
Get it
I'm still alive aren't I I remember now. Oh do you? Oh you remember he killed her
then I do I
I
can't remember all I I can't stop can't stop why I have to look for -
Okay
All right
Oh, I'm back I guess
Cool
So what do I do?
Use the clock key you've opened it okay, so am I gonna hit the spot of this mystery, or is this Gonna haunt me forever?
Well, you got a car another key ok key to the basement now. We know what we need - oh boy
Okay, ah that ain't okay?
Alright, then Gotta go Lottie Dottie down to the dottie duty basement. Oh boy. Oh
boy
I was a close one. Oh
Much more threatening when I can't see
Its unlock now great. So now what oh?
Boy where am I now oh lordy lou? It's a toolbox search for items sure you found a battery great
I don't know why I need that but okay how extent oh
Ammo, box there's only one ammo here loaded sure you've loaded the ammo
What is that have I gotten any mercy what brings you here family you only got us
We're your family
Hahaha, are you insane?
You killed her it's you that caused
Everything you only you're one crazy son. She was still alive
You've ended her misery you took it didn't you?
Hahaha, I'm so confused you thought you could save her with your foolishness you thought you could
I mean, I went to trouble skip. This is this his dad. I think that's who this is
I'm inclined of wait I
Don't know what that's gonna change. What are you? I don't. What are you idling there?
That bullet was waiting there the whole time come on. Kid. Shoot me
Why what are you waiting for come on kid pull the trigger? She loves you more than me the hell
It's you you killed if it was not for your stupidity
She would not have fell I didn't mean to shove her
I was mad, but you because of you she fell now shoot me, so I could be with her
Are you listening to me stop thinking start shooting?
I ain't going to forget what you did, please just shoot
I want to live what I can't bear this leave me alone
Okay, what was that? Okay? All right? Well you stay there. I guess oh
Wouldn't the hell happening? Oh?
Boy, oh boy
And like this hi, hello, I just got home mom
How are you? Are you doing with me mom what oh hi, okay? That's weird
Don't come closer to me. No. Thank you. I don't want mom. Are you alright? I think mom is alright
Did something happen I think you're out of your goddamn mind?
He's resting. Hi did not do anything. He's safe mom. What are you?
Are you angry Stop don't come any closer? What the hell is with you in this gun?
Stop why because of him you died so why I'm gonna shoot. Why do I have a say in this matter? Oh?
Stop okay. I guess I don't what the hell
Ending saving home
Total playtime way too long 40 minutes. What in the fuck what it was
Yeah, what happening was that Brandon Brandon? I have no idea. What just happened
I am at A complete loss, and I have no idea I
Have no idea. Well, that's just something that we're gonna have to deal with
Okay, there you have it. So anyway that was going home. That was a
Mindwarp of a game and yet it was extremely simplistic. I understand that it was extremely simplistic
I can like look past that because what it did with what it had was really really good like the
Ambience was there and I enjoyed it immensely from that the puzzling was a bit like it dragged on a bit
But even so I don't know what the other endings are I don't know if what I got was a good ending
which I kind of like I like the
Ambiguity of it and the mystery of the story can be pieced together by finding the other endings
But even so it was a bit monotonous to go through again, but either way. Hope you guys enjoyed it
Let me know anything down in the comments below
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye Bye~!
*beast&catchy music made by shirk (haunted)*